vamos a las noticias de economía con
jorge hurtado y jorge vamos a empezar
este especial de economía como cada
viernes para hablar de la devaluación de
las monedas emergentes especialmente las
de latinoamérica así es bueno frente a
estas el dólar está recibiendo un fuerte
impulso por la incertidumbre que genera
en los mercados la nueva variante
omicron en latinoamérica el peso
colombiana se ubica entre las monedas
más devaluadas del año seguida del peso
argentino el sol peruano el peso chileno
y el peso mexicano mientras el riise
brasileño muestra leves signos de
apreciación sólo el peso colombiano que
hay en octubre pasado casi seis por
ciento y llegó esta semana a superar la
barrera de los cuatro mil por cada dólar
mientras que el mexicano perdió que hace
5 % y el chileno un 2 por ciento de su
valor frente al dólar conversamos con un
jorge garcía castro el ex experto en
mercados financieros y le consultamos
cuáles son las principales causas que
están llevando a la devaluación de las
monedas latinoamericanas y esto nos
contó
cuando caen las tasas de interés en eeuu
se incrementa el apetito por acciones y
por otros activos de riesgo como por
ejemplo instrumentos de deuda de
soberanos emergentes con colombia méxico
brasil y sobre todo si se ensancha o se
amplía del diferencial entre los
rendimientos de ese tipo de instrumentos
con respecto a los rendimientos de la
deuda soberana estadounidense una vez
comienzan a corregir al alza las tasas
de interés en eeuu que comienza a
cerrarse ese diferencial entre
rendimientos de deuda soberana que por
ejemplo emergentes con respecto a la
deuda soberana es también se pues los
diferentes agentes del mercado
comienzan a liquidar o cerrar posiciones
en ese tipo de activos de riesgo lo que
genera una fuga de capitales de estas
economías emergentes y genera a su vez
en fuertes devaluaciones en el corto
plazo de esas divisas con respecto al
dólar estadounidense adicionalmente esa
liquidación masiva de posiciones en ese
tipo de instrumentos o activos
considerados activos de riesgo
también se lleva a cabo cuando se
incrementa la aversión al riesgo es
decir disminuye el apetito o la
tolerancia por
activos de riesgo actualmente
en eeuu
[Música]
se espera que las tasas de interés suban
más rápido de lo que se esperaba a
inicio del año 2021 la nueva variante
coli
puede extender o acentuar aún más esas
disrupciones de las cadenas de
suministro muy bien y en los últimos
meses los mercados emergentes han sido
sacudidos por varios factores cuéntenos
de eso así entre los cuales podría
enumerar los bloqueos en la cadena de
suministro inclusive la misma crisis
inmobiliaria en china y la altas tasas
de inflación tienen su efecto en la
economía en las economías locales de
hecho cuando el dólar está fuerte a
nivel mundial es normal que la mayoría
de las monedas de otras economías
pierden su valor frente a esta divisa
pero algunos analistas apuestan que los
buenos datos en las materias primas que
mueve el mercado latinoamericano
amortiguó esta tendencia de pérdida de
valor aunque hay otros factores como por
ejemplo los cambios políticos que vive
la región que también influyen le
preguntamos a nuestro invitado sobre los
casos específicos de méxico y de perú
el peso mexicano durante una parte del
2021 había logrado mantenerse fuerte
principalmente porque méxico estaba
logrando atraer y retener capital debido
a los rendimientos de la deuda soberana
denominada pesos mexicanos mucho más
atractivos que por ejemplo aquellos
asociados a la deuda soberana denominada
soles peruanos o denominan pesos
colombianos
teniendo en cuenta y finalmente que la
calidad crediticia al soberano mexicano
actualmente es mucho mejor que la del
soberano colombiano desde la segunda
mitad del 2020 experimenta una fuerte
inestabilidad política este año se
posesionó como presidente el otrora
candidato de izquierda castillo con unas
promesas de campaña que ponen bastante
nerviosos a los mercados entre ellas por
ejemplo convocar una asamblea
constituyente que perú retomen el
control de sus recursos naturales e
incrementar significativamente el gasto
del estado
renegociar los tratados comerciales
cambiar las condiciones
respecto a las relaciones que hay con
las trasnacionales que tienen presencia
en el país
su memoria esto la solicitud de vacancia
presidencial de algunos sectores aunque
no tiene la suficiente fuerza pues
realmente está generando todavía mucho
más ruido político un agradecimiento a
ustedes jorge ya nuestros televidentes
sigan en france 24
[Música]